kyle really is an [ __ ] no for sure  like soon when you know him oh yeah so  nice i've been on record saying it yeah  he's great he has always been very kind  to me but he is an [ __ ] to people who  maybe  don't know him  so  did you always like kyle  no okay no he and he know it and  everybody around like our first year  together because  anybody know me i'm such a  i'm a chill  person a state of myself but i do have a  certain side to me  that i just never want to bring out  and kyle was an [ __ ] to where i knew  if i was around him long enough he would  bring that other side out so i just  stayed away from him  cause i didn't know him i didn't know  him personally to to unders understand  them  um but as time went on and  we just ended up in certain situations  together in the game off the court you  know you start to  learn them understand them more  it was